she found her dad's car in a ditch there  was no blood in the car is as if he  vaporized out of the driver's seat and  just floated away oh yeah  I was father owned the bar and Avenue a  he taken all the cash and left a note  Sonia stego said her dad wrote her a  letter was as if you plan to miss the  next 30 years of her life people used to  vacation here they used to come here for  the lake  my dad said when he was little he'd go  fishing now we just have dust storms  do you have a girlfriend  not really you and boyfriend  [Music]  that's crap what you guys want for it  those bikes  we're just gonna leave like everyone  else what do you want me to think about  there is nothing here Korea asked me  about life on the moon was lake at  sunset they sing all the old songs the  ones grandpa used to sing to us  if you see my baby oh my  [Music]  you